it's a boule Capcom exclusive last time
we talked man I'd asked you about
whether or not you had smashed our
Rachel star because you were out with
her and I'm a big Rachel star fan the
inserts tased the answer has changed so
you have how was it did she ride did she
ride like she rides in the video I don't
see this one he's not even speaker this
because I know she doesn't mind you know
I know she's she's she's so over the
answer has changed so my congratulations
are in order right now yeah we bid a
flick two words I would like to give you
props because just were around the same
age demo and you know coming up as 1890
no kid beat my meat to Rachel oh that's
what's up man everything you and um she
we did a threesome - right she pulled up
it was was it like a chick that she knew
no I was just pulling random or more
like like randomly like this is amazing
go over here was this in Texas cuz I
don't she displeased in Texas and it was
just a crazy day
don't ask her why I know that way make
fun of in front of in front of in front
of everybody just and you got this on Oh
see we got multiple we are multiple we
did it a lot this is amazing now that's
a MGK there any other porn stars that
you have got the kick of it that you
know I've reached out to or that you
know I mean I'm not saying that you've
actually bang but who are some friend
friends of yours in the adult industry
that you can shout out I got a lot good
is there two or three that you know that
might stick out to a porn kind of store
like myself oh definitely well actually
do you know do REME Lacroix is I don't
know that is she's actually just like a
really like
chick up in Amman hardest Skin Diamond
yo abc1 Skin Diamond home bleep on that
one
she's the business what yo thank me
later for ya okay cool
she'd be doing all she be do like
belladonna stuff but she's away on yeah
she looks like Rihanna cut the shade Ted
she's like mix black tatted up yeah I'm
wait you are late on the second you
gotta check her out man
movies because the internet on the bus
sucks maybe that that's it